brady singer he's got something for him
that's for darn sure now look
innings 85 and two-thirds innings he's
been
really good and two down to ryan mount
castle he's the dh
royals wanted him to be somewhat off the
plate that fastball rides in on mount
castle
it strikes him out and completes a one
two three first for brady singer
that is filthy they'll take their swings
off the hard throwing right-hander jorge
lopez there's the numbers on the year 84
and two thirds
the strikeouts are good 81 strikeouts
only 38 walks his last timeout against
the white sox four in each pitch gave up
two runs only walked one
two strikes the count lopez played word
and a swing and a miss
slider chased by merrifield outside the
zone
so there's one gone carlos santana
coming up yeah well if he can throw it
like that
and start it right on the edge because
he had him a fastball out there that he
comes inside another good slider there's
that tight tight spin
starts on the edge at merrifield you can
see the frustration on his face he just
didn't recognize that pitch at all
salvador perez two out of four with two
runs batted in last night
next pitch is grounded sharply up the
middle and into center field
that pitch was 98 but it was faster
going out than it was coming in
good thing it was not directed at jorge
now that's a four-seam fastball with
movement
savvy attacked it short compact swing
that's what develops the bat speed
two and one for t.j stewart there's the
oriole cleanup hitter tonight
second highest walk rate second highest
strikeout rate seven home runs for dj
and in what's been a three true outcomes
type of year here's a base hit
back up the box for dj stewart a single
into center field
there's a spin on it dot on the front
and the back this is one of those ones
it's kind of sitting right in the middle
of the plate
and watch dj stewart nice and balanced
hits it right back from whence it came
something really bubbling here against
singer a single from stewart a walk to
santander and now
where the hitters count for ramon on a
3-1 urias goes to the opposite field and
drops in a hit
stewart will get the wave around third
and santander will go
first to third an rbi single for ramon
urrius
azaria's been good since he's taken over
a little inside out swing ball running
in
on the hands and watch this swing pulls
those hands in really quick to the body
and fights it off
shoots it right over the second baseman
with merrifield's head and a good read
by dj stewart
checked up just for a second but he knew
the ball was out toward right center
field
and a nice job by anthony santander as
well first to third
runners at the corners and nobody out
the pitch
breaking ball is topped right side
merrifield looks at second base has no
play he'll take the out but santander
jogs down to score
and the orioles with a two-nothing lead
give leyva an rbi for his troubles
he's called a good one so far it threw
20 pitches
sebby says put it down and lopez does
curveball to strike out so later
well everything working right now for
jorge lopez the fastball's been up to 98
miles an hour i'll tell you what the two
breaking balls the slider and the curve
have been spot on
ten selections were not pitchers one two
mullins swings and this is a line drive
base hit into right field
mullins turns first looks up digs in for
second ryan o'hern up with the throw and
it's a stand-up double
to start the third for cedric mullins
2-2 count for mancini
singer fires mancini swings it's a
ground ball up the middle
buried by nikki lopez the shortstop from
his knees doesn't get the throw off
in time trey mancini reaches safely with
a base hit cedric mullins advances to
third and it's runners on the corners
but now it's mullins 90 feet from home
and mancini at first for ryan mount
castle
singer fires mount castle swings this is
the ground ball beats the infield coming
home as cedric mullins mancini advances
to second it's three nothing orioles
and then comes dj stewart who had the
first hit and run scored in the second
first pitch stewart swings and he slams
the ball into the right field gap it's
another base hit trey mancini gets the
wave round from
third heading into third in the slide
goes ryan mount castle rbi
single dj stewart it's four nothing o's
santander
at the plate 2-2 santander swings this
one
gets up the left side past hunter dozier
coming home to score easily is ryan
mount castle
d.j stewart advances first to third and
the orioles just continue to trade
places here
santander he reaches safely it's five
nothing orioles
dj stewart at third santander at first
payoff pitch swings line drive
base it left field stuart jogs home it's
six
nothing orioles pedro severino who flied
out
in the second a one severino swings and
this one finds the gap up the left side
charging around
third and heading in right behind comes
santander it's
seven nothing orioles top of the third
and they are pouring it on
he's really been on a good run one and
two right now in the pitch
and he'll swing and ground it by the
pitcher and into center field for a base
hit
well he's been on a roll and he stays on
a roll as that one got by both lopez and
the second baseman
carlos santana grounded out to mancini
at first his first time up
2-0 and a swing and a ball hit the other
way pretty well dj stewart on the run
and he won't get there it's going to
bounce up against the fence
here comes nikki flying around third
he'll come in and score the royals first
run of the night
on a double the other way from carlos
santana
one two mancini swings it's a drive into
right field tracking back ryan o'hearn
out in front of the wall he leaps it's
off the top of his glove mancini
stretches in for second
he rounds heading into third the throw
is cut off and trey mancini
opens the fourth with a triple boy
that's one of those ones when it pops up
out of the hand and you recognize it
right away and you can see
the eyes get really big about right
there and you talk about not getting
food at all trade drives this ball
oh hearn goes up and the ball hits off
the pinky finger of the glove he
couldn't hang on to it and trey mancini
out of the box quickly
nobody out for ryan mount castle who
singled in the first run of five
mount castle drives one the other way as
well
o'hern will make this catch but a run
will score a sacrifice fly
second rbi tonight for ryan mount castle
and the orioles get that run right back
and he'll get ryan o'hearn
michael a taylor and nikki lopez in the
bottom of the fifth inning
and o'hearn goes into center field and
the royals
have their lead off man on for the first
time tonight
here's the o2 pitch and a liner into
right field for a hit
so taylor kept his at bat alive and now
back-to-back singles and the royals have
something going here
he draws the walk and now here's what
marifield who has struck out
twice swinging you don't think he is
motivated and this at bat
[Music]
and that'll get away from severino so a
run will score
it is 8-2 o'haren comes down from third
taylor goes to third lopez moves up to
second base
infield back of course 2-2 pitch and
driven into deep right center field
and over goes to right fielder santander
to make the play but it's going to score
a run
salvia singled and fouled out to the
catcher severino
sally grounds it into left field for a
base hit so he picks up
santana and with the bases loaded and
nobody out the royals eventually get
all three home veterans santana doubled
in a run
struck out and twice grounded out swings
first ball
puts it in the air center field this
should do it mullins backs up
makes the catch and the orioles snap the
slide they've got their first win of the
second half
and they use a big third inning and good
relief pitching
to take it tonight by a final score of
8-4